there is a message that has gone out to
everyone abroad I think it's from the
State Department that says come home now
or you might not be able to come home
that message came out after we were
stuck after we were stuck in Peru I
bought a united flight that was going to
go from Lima to Houston to Denver I had
my boyfriend call United just to confirm
everything and my employ had been
cancelled
and I was never notified and that's when
I started to feel like that's weird you
know the quarantine is supposed to be
over like why don't I have a fly anymore
when we came India only had three cases
and right now they have over 500
literally from one day to the next
everything just changed when we got to
Mumbai it was like okay we're closing
everything down there are no more
flights that were even rebooked eight to
ten times since last Tuesday
if I didn't have a wife and kids to get
back home to I think I would have just
stayed nostri and just given up United
won't be playing back until May I've
heard the same thing about American
things are not just returning to normal
when the quarantine is over and there
have been a lot of rumors that a
quarantine is just going to be extended
in Austria they said okay what we're
gonna do is shut down non-essential
shops and I'm thinking that's not too
big of a deal
the next day or two all the restaurants
shut down I have no kitchen that I
couldn't even find a supermarket that
was open I didn't really know I was
going to occur to you here in India has
been extended until April 14th that
means there are no buses no flights no
means of transportation anywhere these
restrictions that would put in rapid
fire without a lot of recourse for
people that are on the roads so people
were on camping trips or in northern
districts which takes either a domestic
flight which are also suspended for many
many hours of travel by the roads they
just made an announcement today that all
foreigners that arrived after February
15th have to stay inside so that's
making it a little difficult for us to
buy food a lot of people have made
comments like wow what a nice place to
be stuck and I disagree this quarantine
is enforced by martial law you can only
leave your home between 5:00 a.m. and
8:00 p.m. and it's only to go to a bank
pharmacy or grocery store that's it we
step outside to go to the grocery store
and we have to talk to police and tell
them where we're going I stay in this
small little hotel when I'm there
because it's a great location right in
the center of Vienna the weird thing is
that the streets and everything are so
empty so if they don't play around but
if they catch you doing something
obvious is like shaking hands or hugging
you will get fine and I heard it was
like as much as 600 euros there are a
lot of hotels here and hostels that are
not taking any foreigners it was the
article in India Times about a guest
house owner being booked and arrested
for having accepted foreigners that
story alone can create a lot of fear for
people in a position to take us in we
were very lucky to find a hostel here
Ian
andr in Mumbai so right now we're
obeying the lockdown we haven't left our
hotel which is a nice hotel that we
called ahead and said that they would
accept us but we're gonna be running out
of funds soon they're not providing any
meals we don't have any choice but to
pay the hotel restaurant for all of our
food grocery shopping is in theory
available but with the stories that I've
heard about foreigners you know being
threatened with violence we don't feel
so we can leave just to get basic
supplies we were trying to buy food
yesterday and people did not want to
sell us anything because we were
foreigners they simply said go away we
are closed for the night we're closed
for the day
it's been a little difficult we've came
across discrimination even just two days
ago we were walking in the street
looking for food and people started
yelling Korona at me and my friend so
that when I said okay it's time to reach
out to the embassy the reply and I kid
you not was one sentence that's that if
you're having problems finding a quiet
back well we recommend that you try
Expedia or Google flights to find an
alternate that is the US Embassy's reply
to me our first call to the US Embassy
was on Saturday the 21st they highly
recommended that we get out before the
22nd which at that point was 12 hours
away which is when the suspension of the
international flights was happening and
we had just been able to secure our
entry into Delhi and to get to a hotel
so the traveling that we were doing on
land was difficult and we weren't able
to make that happen
the US Embassy hasn't really gotten back
to our situation directly it emailed
them so many times and it says to only
email them once and wait for a response
but when I finally do get responses
they're just automated I do not want to
be forgotten here it's very difficult
for someone that has never had dealings
of the US Embassy not to know what you
can ask like repatriation loans I didn't
know that that was a thing until you
know two days later we're thinking is
there gonna be a week two weeks a month
two months that's what's stressing us
out right now we might be here for the
full 21 days and then maybe be hoping
that it's only 21 days and then you know
I would have to do what the embassy
suggested which is start sourcing funds
from friends and family at home I'm
hoping that the US embassy can
organize a car for us with the proper
documentation and at least get us to
Lima so we're available for when our
names do come up on the chartered
flights we're willing to do anything to
get back home at this point whether is
paying for fly troubled for two days if
necessary anything we just want to get
back home to our families in a time
that's filled with so much an
uncertainty you just want to be close to
your family